making a dent in our housing crisis this
morning there's a new affordable option
for Las Vegas this historic West Side
Lauren negretti joining us live in The
Newsroom this morning with a look at how
the project is helping Revitalize that
area Lauren good morning to you good
morning you guys that's right the
unveiling of that six unit building is
happening later this morning courtesy of
Neighborhood Housing Services the units
are under 600 square feet one bedroom
one bath located in the first
African-American area created within the
segregation era of Las Vegas the project
is part of the city of Las Vegas and
unlv's 100 plan initiative to revitalize
the area a mission that's dear to their
Chief Operating Officer who grew up just
a Stones throw away
it's near and dear to my heart it is uh
it's probably a driving passion for us
to make sure that that this area is
revitalized in a way that I remember it
as my youth now two of those six units
are still up for grabs you can call that
number on your screen eligibility is
income based making between 30 and 80 of
the area median income
and she says that people were driven
away from the near from the area due to
nearby crime homeless encampments and
they're hoping to Breathe new life into
the area the city of Las Vegas has a
whole lot more planned for that
historically overlooked part of town and
we've got more details for you on our
website at 8newsnow.com in The Newsroom
Laura Negrete 8 News Now